[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce pacte spéciale
présidentielle nous allons regarder le
visage de la france et le visage des
yvelines après le premier tour du
scrutin et pour en parler florence
mercadé choqué bonjour patrice avocate
au barreau de versailles l'euro mazaury
bourgeois adjoint au maire de l'anc au
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines et président de tv 78 j'ai tout
dit et qu'au fond dames porte-parole de
l'ue 10 pour les histoires des paroles
de midi pour les yvelines
jean charles lajoie dit bonjour bonjour
vous êtes éditeur toujours et je me
libère fait on est au printemps ça y est
vous y fait beau mais divers finit
toujours par arriver et leurs histoires
de
concerne un peu l'islamisme d ça
concerne trappe voilà comment on n'est
pas loin oui un calife installé à
trappes c'est quoi le prix de l'évêché
péché c'est l'hôtel de police de
marseille et qui distribue qui fait un
prix littéraire qui est vraiment
vraiment bien et donc voilà cet auteur
obtenu ce prix pour son précédent livre
dire ça va payer celui là est vraiment
on peut un peu angoissant par moments
mais mais d'actualité voilà avis
totalement totalement nicolas gendry
bonjour si jean patrice est journaliste
à tv 78 vous avez notamment suivi la
campagne de valérie pécresse les
résultats de valérie pécresse j'ai dit
avec elle vous étiez vous avez passé
votre soirée dimanche avec elle c'est ça
faisait 6 delà du roman tellement ça
occupe chez la maison de la chimie à
paris avec plusieurs militants et ses
soutiens et là vous allez sortir votre
carnet de chèques parce que fo ce
qu'elle appelle aux dons l'appel aux
dons et avec nos visions bonjour vincent
couronne me jean patrice vous êtes le
fondateur des surligneurs qui regarde
voilà qu'est ce qui se dit dans les
discours politiques ce qui est
applicable pas applicables notamment sur
le plan juridique et vous êtes aussi
enseignant à l'université versailles
saint quentin
alors on va commencer peut-être par le
le visage de cette france du 10 avril
qu'est ce que nous disent des résultats
de ce premier tour
[Musique]
alors on va commencer d'ailleurs par le
ballet les deux gagnants les résultats
macro le pen on nous disait des sondages
de disette et français ne voulaient pas
de ce match retour et pourtant il a dû
premier gagnant c'est la participation
alors on a quand même eu un grand serait
pas très en retrait à la finale elle ne
l'est pas il ya même une progression
donc déjà un la démocratie a gagné
je veux si c'était un autre gagnant
c'est d'ailleurs répondre à ceux qui
sont pour l'abstention qui disent
toujours personne ne représente mes
idées je crois qu'on avait un panel
complet de l'ensemble de tout ce qui
peut se faire en matière d'idées
politiques à cycliste de saint médard ya
des gens qui disent ah ben moi je trouve
pas je vois un tel arc-en-ciel de
représentation potentiel ça fait le
deuxième gagnant je commence par ça et
puis effectivement après pour reprendre
ce que vous disiez patrice on voulait
pas de ce débat voulait pas de ce match
mais à la finale on là et ça me semble
assez logique compte tenu de l'évolution
des intentions de vote que nous avait
annoncé les sondeurs et des différents
mouvements qui a pu y avoir d'autres
différents candidats et à la finale
effectivement on rejoue ce qui s'est
passé la dernière fois mais avait quand
même des médias jugement différent cette
recomposition du paysage politique était
comble remaniée et des partis qui sont
en jeu parlait même pas du parti
socialiste me prendra peut-être toute à
l'heure enfin là qui sont carrément
voire quasiment d'extinction aujourd'hui
tout cas leur candidat et y compris pour
pour ce qui s'est passé chez a l'air
aussi sur lequel il ya de vraies
questions à se poser de recomposition du
paysage politique pendant que nous en
parlons on voit en effet le l'abstention
26 31 en france
les yvelines ont plutôt mieux veut plus
voter encore que que le reste de la
moyenne nationale oui c'est pas c'est
pas une abstention énorme
enfin comment nous l'annoncions il ya
plus de votants par exemple pour 2002
c'est une abstention à peu près normale
un score extraordinaire quand même deux
fois plus qu'à d'hidalgo
notées çà c'est donc il pourrait devenir
maire de paris
sans aucun problème on aurait des
bistrots à tous les coins de rue saab
service à nouveau sac ville agréable à
vivre
agréable à vivre d'ailleurs dans son
village de lourdios ichère dans les
pyrénées atlantiques où que ce soit
solidere voilà exactement palois
d'origine mais hélas à lourdios ichère
il fait 60 % mairie mental il est alors
que anne hidalgo fake 2% à paris je
pourrais répéter il faut qu'enfin vinsot
justement alors ce match retour le pen
macron mâcon le pen il s'explique aussi
sociologiquement c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'on a quand même de
france qui s'affrontent la france un peu
d la france d'aider des grandes
métropoles la france de la périphérie
c'est ce que disait il hier
dans ce livre qui s'appelle de
l'archipel français c'est ce qui était
assez démontré c'est à dire que on a une
nouvelle structure sociologique qui a
des applications politique
oui alors sur le détail de la carte
électorale et des résultats du vote dans
les différentes circonscriptions en tout
cas un peu partout en france la
distinction entre les villes et les
campagnes il me semble qu'elle est assez
elle est assez nette mais elle n'est pas
forcément elle est pas forcément
entièrement nouvelle ce qui est en
revanche nouveau en tout cas ceux qui
commencent à s'affirmer petit à petit
c'est une personnification de plus en
plus important de la vème république et
de cette élection présidentielle au
point où désormais même si encore une
fois c'est pas nouveau mais c'est
quelque chose qui s'implante de plus non
plus et qui désormais la a éclaté au
grand jour avec cette élection là c'est
vraiment la place de la personne
candidate
devant même son programme on a bien vu
emmanuel macron qu'il ya très peu fait
campagne donc assez peu de gens pour
réciter à part la retraite à 65 ans on
pourrait citer des promesses des
éléments de programme emmanuel macron
assez peu fait campagne et et marine le
pen en face qui a réussi à se
dédiaboliser facialement parce que son
programme lune il n'a pas changé et est
toujours un programme d'extrême droite
et donc on a une différence une
divergence de perception entre les
personnes et les programmes tout
simplement parce que les personnes ont
pris vraiment la première place et dans
ce schéma là il est possible d'avoir une
polarisation extrêmement forte qu'on
peut voir entre les villes et vente
évidemment et les campagnes mais une
polarisation parce qu'elle se fait
autour des personnes et non pas autour
des programmes et c'est beaucoup plus
facile de polarisé autour des personnes
parce qu'on va polariser a grondé
phrases autour des apparitions
médiatiques autour des structurations
notamment aussi des réseaux sociaux
plutôt que de polariser autour des
programmes et c'est ça qui s'est passé
aussi il y à il ya quelques jours
mais il ya quand même on voit si on
regarde un petit peu filmant les
résultats c'est à dire qu'il ya d'un
côté votre mac row les gens qui sont
plutôt s'appeler fille mais plutôt aisés
et les classes populaires votent plutôt
le pen au final et il faudra parler de
mélenchon aussi mais il ya quand même on
a l'impression quand même qu'à 2 france
quoique et qui s'affrontent et que cet
affrontement des deux francis traduit
politiquement parce par ce match retour
dont les sondages disaient que le
français ne voulaient pas bon je voyais
un sondage justement sur le niveau de
revenu
par rapport
aux candidats et c'est vrai que
macron est à des niveaux de revenu vers
4 5 mille euros donc c'est pas que ce
sont des classes plutôt aisée et marine
le pen était aux alentours de 3000 donc
on ne peut pas dire que c'est ultra
populaire 3000 euros c'est déjà quand
même un revenu qui n'équipe qui est
conséquent en revanche c'est mélenchon
qui est assurent des revenus 2005 2000
euros donc c'est vraiment lui qui est
plus en réalité par rapport à ces
sondages beaucoup plus sur le peuple
entre guillemets sur les personnes qui
on a des revenus plutôt faibles et les
jeunes s'explique beaucoup les jeunes
les jeunes qui veut sont pour une grande
partie dans une précarité et dans une
dans une pauvreté ceux qui vivent dans
des dans des familles aisées peuvent
voter mélenchon mais peuvent aussi à
voter main à voter macron
n'enlève pas un truc qui est quand même
très inquiétant c'est que macron fait
effectivement 27% des voix comme à quoi
qu'on pense du personnage c'est quand
même un démocrate absolue enfin je
dirais il ya aucun aucun souci avec les
et derrière on à l'extrême droit puis
l'extrême gauche avec mélenchon que moi
quand on a quand même c'est quand même
terrible ça fait quasiment 50% à 50 pour
cela fait cinq ans qu'ils sont
extrémistes de gauche ou de droite c'est
moi c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement angoissant de vote en gros
qu'on pourrait dire pour protestataires
si aux yeux enfin hors système plus si
on rajoute de l'abstention ça fait 70 %
tracé comme mais c'est quand même énorme
donc ça c'est effectivement un p c'est
vrai alors peut-être un singe pas il
faudra réfléchir un jour mais peut-être
que ces élections présidentielles aussi
ne favorise pas le discours modéré le
discours de nuances c'est vrai que le
discours le discours tenu en ce moment
chez makro qu'il tient
rien de concret si
elle arrêtait vous dis mais si ce n'est
pas idéal mais il y avait quelque chose
mais mme effectivement les héros gros et
c'est ce qui explique aussi peut-être un
peu la faillite des partis dits de
gouvernement c'est que voilà quand vous
êtes dans la complexité c'est le message
est peut-être plus difficile à faire
passer les qualifs enfants qu'on puisse
dire que ce soit la faillite des partis
parce que ma candeur je vais revenir sur
mes macs ronsin président de droite
enfin je veux dire donc que pécresse
parce que quatre ennemis si la tendance
est actuellement parce que
c'est pas gênant enfin je dirais non ce
qu'ils quittent ce qui est assez
intéressant alors il le souligner assez
macro enfin c'est qu'en effet il est le
premier président
exerçant réellement le pouvoir à faire
plus
donc
présentant ce qui est quand même dans
une époque de dégagisme qui combine ses
forts gains de ces remarquables
penguin très intéressant ce que dit
vincent couronne et on en a déjà parlé
sur ce plateau et ça va dans le sens de
effectivement on n'a pas les parties la
réflexion xterra l'analyse et c'est
plutôt les gens qui sont un peu rapide
etc on est moins dans le fond et plus
sur la forme c'est je crois que nous les
médias en jouant ce rôle largeur c'est
qu'effectivement les réseaux sociaux
c'est calibrée en nombre de caractères
et enduré il faut parler vite il faut
être direct et en plus de cela
maintenant effectivement il faut des
gens qui soient pardon pour ce que je
vais dire mais qu'ils soient bons qui
parle bien en fait il faut des acteurs
et quelque part c'est ce qui s'est passé
aussi collection d'ukraine c'est à dire
on voit bien aujourd'hui que qu'elle
rien qui a été un acteur qui a été connu
que la visibilité peut gagner une
élection et le phénomène et moore c'est
quoi c'est exactement la même chose je
sors d'avoir été sur 1000 et 10 et
pendant très longtemps tout d'un coup je
j'apparais alors en pleine lumière lors
après évidemment s'y attaqueront je
m'écroule mais dans un premier temps ge
donc très fort et après je disparais est
celui qui a du fond qui est beau qui
parle bien qui s'habille bien qu'ils
s'expriment bien qui est jeune et qui
mettrait des réseaux sociaux hélas elle
ou il a toutes les chances d'être et le
sait pas s'il est mort je vous parle m
un pick up par exemple
sorti la même chose mais normes
n'étaient pas bons mais ils avaient été
apportés par l'état et de tension
française pour n'était pas dire que
castex no 15 heures
drone fabriqué pendant mes
nicolas
en fait on voit que l'espace politique
il est occupé aujourd'hui par emmanuel
macron qui remplace entre guillemets qui
laisse peu de marge en tout cas pour les
partis de gouvernement le ps parti
socialiste et les rives et loïc est
aujourd'hui la composition politique
elle est clair c'est qu'il ya un espace
assez large qui va de la droite de
gouvernement jusqu'à la gauche de
gouvernement en passant par le centre
qui est occupée par emmanuel macron et
qui laisse à côté les extrêmes forcément
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
vincent si on ajoute
marine le pen zemmour ciotti
dupont aignan c'est là on arrive quand
même à 45% à peu près de devoir c'est
que
c'est pas une question pas de savoir
c'est bien c'est mal fermée comment peut
expliquer comment on explique ce
phénomène au fond l idée de bons skis
les franco français
ce qui est des plus vastes que ça
ce phénomène il est s'explique en partie
parce que par par cette polarisation en
fait autour des 7 autour de comment dire
de la personne candidate et n'ont pas
forcément de son programme et par le
fait que marine le pen qui faisait peur
encore en 2017 ne fait plus en tout cas
fait beaucoup moins peur aujourd'hui en
tout cas facialement encore une fois
parce que je le répète son programme
reste un programme d'extrême droite y
met et donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
facilite énormément évidemment sa
popularité et le fait qu'on puisse
envisager qu'elle soit élue dans une
dizaine de jours ailleurs en europe on
ne voit pas ce phénomène de manière
aussi claire ailleurs en europe il
existe encore en fait les partis
traditionnels même s'ils sont
bouleversés où vous ont pu être
bouleverser un peu comme en espagne un
petit peu en allemagne etc par des
parties un petit peu challenger un petit
peu comme la république en marche en
france où des partis parfois un peu plus
d'extrême droite ou encore plus
peut-être plus de gauche radicale je
pense notamment au portugal et à
l'espagne
mais ce sont des choses ce sont des
mouvements qui ont un peu fait qu'ils
ont pas fait long feu et qui n'ont pas
duré ce sont pas installées dans la
durée en tout cas il ya aussi fortement
que ce qui se passe en france et donc ce
qui inquiète ce qui inquiète notamment
les européens aujourd'hui aussi bien sur
le reste du monde qui regarde un petit
post élections françaises c'est la
possibilité curiosité européenne que
cette possibilité que l'extrême droite
puisse arriver au pouvoir quelque chose
qui n'est pas envisagée ni au royaume
uni ni en allemagne ni même en espagne
en autriche il ya pu avoir une coalition
avec l'extrême droite mais on n'a jamais
eu comme ça dans un pays aussi grand et
aussi stratégique
stratégiquement important que la france
la possibilité comme parti d'extrême
droite une candidate d'extrême droite
arrive au pouvoir où ça vraiment c'est
une singularité française et je la mets
en tout cas sur le compte de cette
personne ait fait cette personnalisation
à outrance de l'élection présidentielle
qui a fait que on a regardé la personne
marine le pen avec ses chats plutôt que
son programme c'est à dire un programme
qui est quand même largement xénophobes
voire racistes et qui n'est pas un
programme qui commentait le programme
qui a vocation à mettre en danger la
république notamment la séparation des
pouvoirs la préservation des droits et
c'est
tout à fait raison parce que on a voulu
tellement diaboliser zemmour que du coup
on a béatifié marine le pen depuis trois
mois ces moments clés comme le faisant
on l'a montré marine le pen avec ses
chats on a fait un reportage sur elle en
colocation avec sa copine elle est
devenue quelqu'un de tout à fait qu'on
avait quasiment envie de l'inviter pour
boire une bière avec jean lassalle
coiffe donc je vais rien mais c'est un
entend d'ailleurs des gens qui disent le
jour du vote on pourrait essayer puis si
la bâche mois on passera quelle joie
quel soutien dans cinq ans comme si
comme s'il n'y avait pas alors je
n'étais pas
d'accord nicolas la stratégie de sa
campagne beaucoup quittent les sujets de
pouvoir d'achat jeunes vont finalement
puis au vu du contexte c'était la
préoccupation des français alors que
eric zemmour s'occuper de sa partie du
programme de sécurité d'immigration on
sait très bien que marine le pen est
aussi sur ces sujets du coup moins
d'assauts ciel n'avait pas besoin
d'insister parce que l'airé eric zemmour
le faisait pour elle et finalement elle
insisté sur la préoccupation des
français le pouvoir d'achat danger sting
qui a quand même aussi quelque chose qui
touche au fond du fait de créer le front
national de toutes pièces alors que les
partis qui sont sont succédé depuis 40
ans n'ont jamais quand même traiter la
problématique de l'identité nationale de
la rendu du renforcement de nos
frontières alors que tous les autres
états dont on parle et qui disent
aujourd'hui ou comment se fait-il qu'en
est il des cons france l'extrême ans
devait arriver c'est l'extrême droite
qui arrive en tant que extrême droite
c'est le message qu'il porte un peu
comme l'écologie voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est que le parti écologique
devrait pas exister sur vous êtes tous
de l'écologie l'extrême bord devait pas
exister si on avait une politique claire
au traité l'immigration d'une certaine
façon renforcer les contrôles aux
frontières se dire qui on veut qu'il
vienne chez nous qui ne veut pas qu'ils
viennent qui on veut qui repart quel
typologie des migrations veut fasse que
tous les autres pays du monde d'où
qu'ils soient fond c'est à des jeux et
c'est pas une politique d'extrême droite
à un moment vous ne traitez pas ce sujet
là et c'est pareil pour les maquereaux
il nous manque cette jambe là bas
évidemment vous laisser cette porte à
tous les autres pour le récupérer avec
une vision beaucoup plus extrémiste et
pour exister moi les gens qui me disent
aujourd'hui au bureau doivent ils ne
disent pas aux braves at il dit en
sortant j'ai voté marine le pen jamais
vous n'avez pas cette typologie dit oui
mais un code-barres zemmour oui mais
traite un sujet dont personne ne
s'occupe pas si vous vous occupez pas du
sujet il ya une place pour que les gens
s'en occupe même chose pour l'écologie
si vous en occupez pas il existe un
parti belgique si vous en occuper bah il
y aurait effectivement une semaine au
même niveau que son père il ya trente
ans on a laissé faire on a mis en place
tout un tas de choses où les gens se
disent je ne suis plus chez moi vision
caricaturale etc et pas xénophobe qui
est juste liés à la visibilité à la
perception prenant là et à ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui si vous laissez
effectivement vous avez effectivement
une diabolisation d'une partie d'une
part en terme d'image et qu'en même
temps vous ne traitez pas le problème
évidemment vous laissez des extrêmes a
perduré existé et c'est la même chose
pour aider fille pardon et les filles
ont dit oui mais alors c'est le parti du
oak hills m'épuise aide beaucoup d
étrangers chez nous mais c'est normal si
vous occupez pas des étrangers qui sont
chez vous si vous les aidez pas vous
voulez vous leur permettez pas d'arrivée
vous le remettez pas toutes les chances
en ligne évidemment quelqu'un les
récupère c'est démocratiquement logique
et c'est pas juste lié qu'à la
personnalité de jean-luc mélenchon bien
sûr c'est avec ses ventes orateurs on
peut retrouver là peu ce que marine le
pen est devenue aujourd'hui parce que
c'est également une excellente oratrice
oui mais il porte aussi des idées qu'on
n'a pas traité
je pense qu'en complément à jeu tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que vous dites et
en complément c'est qu'elle s'est emparé
avec jean luc mélenchon du problème du
pouvoir d'achat aussi et et ça il ya des
tas de personnes qui sont à la rue qui
ont un pouvoir d'achat très faible tout
en travaillant avec pouvoir les
infirmières qu'on voit les enseignants
il ya des vraies problématiques sur ces
sujets là il ce matin j'entendais une
parce que marine le pen était sur france
inter et il y avait 1
auditrice qui et qui était dû voter
mélenchon au premier tour et qui disait
à marine le pen combat qu'est mois de
beauté pour vous parce que je ne voterai
jamais emmanuel macron je ne
m'abstiendrai pas parce que le aller
voter est extrêmement important pour la
démocratie je ne voterai pas blanc donc
maintenant convaincus et moi de voter
pour vous
si elle vaut de pablo c'est que ça ne
vient pas des autres amateurs de mon
avis
l'internet est un peu mais
c'est clair qu'elle
a terminé son intervention en disant moi
j'ai 61 ans baffinland je travaille
longtemps parce que j'ai eu pareille une
carrière hachée et parce que j'ai un
pouvoir d'achat extrêmement faible et
vous vous parlez du pouvoir d'achat est
évidemment marine le pen a embrayé si on
regarde les statistiques de pouvoir
d'achat plutôt monté peu
après après il ya là il ya la réalité
bien il ya la réalité ressentie enfin
c'est comme le comme la nature
et il ya aussi il ya aussi un phénomène
qui est quand même assez assez important
qui est qui ressortit d'open partie
importante de la population c'est une
sorte de vague de haine qui macron enfin
de de rejet de ressentiment et est
toujours de président patrice
pas plus pas moins on détestait nicolas
sarkozy rappelez vous allez on déteste
et par leur nom se moquer lui disant bon
c'est ridicule enfin c'est typiquement
français c'était très bien on est dit
quelqu'un alors le problème c'est que là
il aura pas les 100 jours mais
d'habitude on a 100 jours pour être bon
et puis à partir du 101e jour bien il
rien faire les gens sont dans la rue ça
sera la même chose peut être y aura même
pas les 100 jours non je pense que enfin
on est resté typiquement ma révolution
française on adore adulé le vous savez
c'est comme on adore la couronne
d'angleterre lycée magnifique qu'est ce
que ça va intéresser aux amis anglais et
en même temps on brûle des rois on leur
coupe la tête donc les
c'est très français 7 millions de
journées voter pour lui
c'est pas une telle détestation c'est
vrai que on a une image qui est quand
même un peu un peu troublé oui tout le
monde le déteste balle à la fois frais
tout beau nom mais voilà pour ils ne
semblent ressentir bar - adore parler
c2c on en parle souvent sorte encore une
fois c'est le tracasse pas leur version
donner la parole à quelqu'un qui va dire
le brisant d'un public il est super je
les adore on s'en fiche par contre celui
qui va dire je le déteste on va lui
donner la parole honnêtement c'est aussi
ça en effet que les ou pour exemple les
opposants au président sont de plus en
plus haineux alors qu'avant la zone
avant devaient considérer qu'on était
pour un type de gauche par un type de
droite et on pouvait de passer sharp et
ne pas traiter le type de tous les noms
et c'est alors que là maintenant dès
qu'on déteste mâcon
c'est vrai qu'on l'a jury vous avez tous
tous contre un envol je suis tout à fait
d'accord parce que je regardais je
lisais ce qui se passait au temps de la
troisième république alors je rappais
tentative de crime de meurtre
s'il
y avait eu
du temps de clemenceau je sais plus quel
prix dans la république était mort et
dans le journal demain matin avec les
morceaux qui dit le président machin est
mort j'ai compté tous les français ce
matin il ne manque pas un
seul axe son côté l'action française
non mais je fais je parlais parler
pendant la soirée au même temps il y
avait des oui vincent couronnes 9 oui je
dis effectivement je suis d'accord avec
ce que dit jean charles sur les
questions de haine et en politique
aujourd'hui marivaux peine c'est pas
ça pas été la seule à parler de pouvoir
d'achat jean luc mélenchon aussi par les
pouvoir d'achat emmanuel macron aussi
pour parler de pouvoir d'achat il me
fuit depuis un moment avec la guerre en
ukraine et les différentes tensions au
sortir de la crise du cofide en réalité
pourquoi est-ce que c'est marine le pen
qui a cristallisé un petit peu le vote
en faveur du pouvoir d'achat tout
simplement parce que elle elle n'a pas
elle ne dégage est pas cette même
aversion que pouvait dégager peut-être
quelqu'un comme jean luc mélenchon qui
effectivement une personnalité peut-être
peut-être plus clivante aujourd'hui que
cette marine le pen qui s'est tellement
adouci dans les médias et dans son
discours que final c'est pas le pouvoir
d'achat mais peut-être le pouvoir des
chats qui a pris part
c'est très bien
enfin on va peut-être passer aussi alors
on en parlé un petit peu au début
il y avait beaucoup de gens qui disaient
on va retrouver le clivage droite-gauche
sa part veut ni un terrain c'était 2017
est une exception on voit là qu'au
contraire le phénomène s'est
considérablement aggravée
rappelé anne hidalgo fait -2% valérie
pécresse diviser par quatre le score de
françois fillon dont étiez donc dimanche
avec avec elle valérie pécresse
effectivement au qg de valérie pécresse
bas ce qui se passait c'est que le
constat était clair et déjà la vitrine
avait pas beaucoup de militants valérie
pécresse a fait son discours elle a
annoncé qu'elle allait voter emmanuel
macron second tour est alors par contre
l'élément de langage qui était présent
c'est que l a pas fait
2 elle n'a pas donné d'ordre de vote
pour le sur des motos n'a pas donné de
consigne de vote pour le second tour dit
est souffle encore aimé le discours elle
souffle en fait en disant voilà si
marine le pen est au pouvoir ce sera
catastrophique pour la france
donc en fait c'est à demi mot une
consigne de vote pouvaient absolument
ces essais on sent bien qu'ils aient une
gêne c'est à dire que ben
personnellement c'est un des problèmes
d'ailleurs peut-être de valérie pécresse
sait qu'elle n'a jamais été elle-même
dans cette campagne et me semble-t-il
c'est directement de résultats de la
primaire
recomposée entre la droite de la droite
et puis et centristes qui restait encore
pour l'élu dei qui va soutenir et à leur
donner la conciliation est impossible et
quelque part en fait qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec emmanuel macron c'est
aussi la roue des compositions du mp qui
rappelez-vous aînés de saint jacques
sorbonne une première partie de l'udf
puis j'aurai absorbe une deuxième fois
partir dans les yvelines dont la
majorité des 8 et des udf rejoint l'ump
est aujourd'hui ça sera décomposé des
anciens udf se disent mais non moi je
suis plutôt macron parce que je suis
plutôt centre droit est certainement pas
extrême droite je suis très républicain
au sens de l'appliquer car majuscule et
concilier marcher sur ses deux jambes
warsaw ces trois jambes là c'est très
très compliqué quand vous avez derrière
vous des lieutenants qui vous serez en
disant un j'aurais mettra peut être à ta
place ça ça reste quand même on connaît
êtres humains et les élus et des
politiques qu'ils avaient envie 2 je
t'aime et je soutiens mais pas trop en
même temps je te surveille et si tu sors
de la ligne qui est un peu trop la
mienne ça va mal se passer les
conclusions elles vont trouver à être au
centre de la droite avec effectivement
des gens qui tient vers mâcon et qui
tire vers une tendance
un nouvel examen avec les
régionalisation sud est avec eux un ump
du salaire du sud est qui est une espèce
de deux heures droit choses étranges
venus d'ailleurs vous dans lequel il
convainc nôtres intuitive arrière mais
quand je m'exprime je m'exprime
fortement alors c'est pas ma nature je
pense que c'est très compliqué tout ça
de près ce qu'elle a fait ce qu'elle ne
savait pas faire et ce qu'elle ne
voulait pas faire c'est aussi toute la
bêtise des primaires qui découle du fait
que les deux grands partis les sexes
grands partis qui sont le parti de
valérie pécresse comme le parti
socialiste ne sont plus gérés par des
gens qui ont une quelconque envergure
mais pas de sorte de secrétaires
généraux c'est olivier faure qui n'a
absolument pas le charisme d'une huître
et christian jacob qu'avec un bon
technicien de la politique mêlée c'est
marrant parce que cette suspension pas
tenu qu'à l'époque c'était il y avait
des présidents de parti qui prenait le
batteur gênent le pouvoir mais je des
résidentes partis qui sont qui sont
président du groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale
c'est à dire c'est à dire que christian
jacob et je crois que je crois que il a
était restée en jacob a été président il
a été élu président du groupe pouvaient
absolument les républicains à
l'assemblée nationale est aujourd'hui
olivier faure je crois qu'ils aient pris
qui et c'est olivier faure qui est
président du groupe mais les socialistes
vous avez raison non mais alors d'abord
autrefois il y avait des leaders il fait
qu'il n'y avait pas de prévert c'est pas
le problème qu'on sarkozy se présente
comme chirac se présente je vois ça mais
il faisait mais quand même le parti de
de gaulle de chirac et de sarkozy qui
fait moins de 5 % le parti de mitterrand
et de l'ordre qui fait une belle course
à penser que la paire tchèque slovaque
aimé et quant aux primaires est là vous
avez raison de dire ce que vous dites
mais si vous reporter au moment où il ya
eu ces primaires et l'air qui avaient
été contestés d'abord dit dans la
première ferme et ce baptême et puis
quand allure à
formidable il ya eu
son décès ce sera assurée à bon compte
vous connaissez j'aime qu'une seule j'ai
aucune sympathie pour l'extrême gauche
et pour mélenchon mais ce que vous
imaginez mélenchon faire une primaire
non sens de la france intimes est ce
qu'on imagine valérie le pen marine le
pen faire une prise balai finity vos
pensées la primaire
qu'elle soit interne qu'elle soit
ouverte ça ne marche pas c'est le
premier tour des élections
présidentielles celle devant un bar
vous le faites en trois tours là on va
même pas faire en trois tours 25 tours
une primaire de deux tours plus de
législatives mais comment voulez vous
enfin c'est lunaire a effectivement au
monde deux leaders charismatiques ou si
il sont puis alors après on va se la
raconter au sein des partis c'est un peu
il vaut mieux à l'ennemi que personnel
plutôt que quelqu'un est arrivé que ce
n'est pas moi donc je les autres alice
tout le monde vous faites une primaire
tous vont se neutraliser après on prend
un milieu qui satisfasse l'ensemble des
extrémités de du parti mais ça me va
aborder ça fonctionne pas ça fonctionne
temporairement parce qu'effectivement
nous les médias on donne à visiter ces
primaires et s'est fait la main ça vaut
pas ce qu'on apprend on voit les gens
donc forcément ça mon puis dès que la
primaire est finie au pape sa redescente
de télévision et les divisions continuer
de rassurer puis officiellement que se
tiendra que je soutiens par jalousie ou
trouvé qu'au parti socialiste anne
hidalgo étaient très soutenue par les
éléphants qui restent et regardez pas
entendu la possibilité unique reste
justement d'arriver à retenir ciotti
jacques
rousseau qui a passé j'entends essai de
déconstruire jeu
adverse et définitivement pas un système
français où enfin
je pense qu'effectivement ça a pas l'air
d'être un système français cette
primaire ça prend pas ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne pas depuis qu'on les met en
place à quelques exceptions près
françois hollande mais qui est arrivée
qui a remporté la primaire dans des
circonstances un peu particulières
puisqu'il prenait la place un petit peu
de dominique strauss kahn qui avait été
empêchée pour les raisons que l'on sait
donc mais ça fonctionne pas aussi je
pense peut-être que pour une des raisons
c'est que la culture démocratique en
france est très faible malgré tout et
que cette culture démocratique elles
font l aile faible tient uniquement
grâce à l'élection présidentielle on n'a
pas cette culture par exemple
parlementaire du compromis
de la coalition en france comme on peut
la voir dans quasiment tous les autres
pays européens et donc une primaire en
fait c'est ça c'est une sorte d'
élections parlementaires interne à un
parti politique à l'issue de laquelle le
chef le cube est candidat qui a été qui
a été élu doit faire des compromis avec
toutes les composantes de son parti
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
envisageable et qui se fait en allemagne
qui fonctionne qui fonctionne en espagne
qui fonctionne en autriche etc mais qui
ne fonctionne pas en france parce que
justement on n'a pas cette culture
parlementaire démocratique en france on
a la culture du chef et du chef
charismatique il pas pourquoi une bonne
mise hors jeu pas avec en termes de
démocratie en france compromis égale
compromission dès qu'on parle d'accord
déménagement magouilles voilà donc bah
mission va pas refaire l'histoire mais
même si enfin en effet vous avez raison
de dire qu'à l'exception de dowland
qu'il faudrait tempéré parce que du coup
il a laissé quand même à martine aubry
ne soit désigné les candidats à la
députation et ça lui valut les fraudeurs
toxiques et au look pourrait absolument
son quinquennat nicolas donc il ya eu
aussi des réactions du côté de l air
effectivement bd le soir même un au qg
de valérie pécresse et bien on a croisé
notamment alexandra dublanche donc vis
conseils régionaux projet de valérie
pécresse et on va l'écouter
notre partis restent unis pour les
combats prochain à mener et donc
effectivement pas une voix à l'extrême
droite bat l'ebbe classe a toujours eu
une position très tranchée face à aux
extrêmes et donc voilà c'est tout à fait
cohérent avec sa position il ya un
espace politique pour ce projet ça c'est
certain j'en suis persuadé je reste
persuadé que ce projet est le meilleur
pour l'avenir du pays et donc il faut
qu'on continue à le pousser à le
défendre a commencé lors des élections
législatives bien évidemment je pense
que déjà faut présenter nos idées donc
c'est ça l'enjeu c'est à présenter les
idées que je porterai face à tous ces
enjeux dont on n'aime pas les dont on
n'a pas du tout parlé pendant la
présidentielle et voilà avec des
solutions actuelles dont on ne se
satisfait absolument pas et donc ça va
être ça la campagne est de défendre
c'est un territoire bien sûr auquel je
suis très attaché dans la 5e
circonscription des yvelines et donc
elle que je connais très bien sur lequel
je travaille depuis cinq ans
donc voilà on sait que sa candidature
déjà annoncé sa candidature pour le
jeter dans la cinquième série d'actes
mansat donc prochaine étape les
législatives mais avant cela il ya eu un
bureau politique hier au siège du parti
les républicains tout le monde s'est
rassemblé alors il ya un accord qui est
tombé enfin en tout cas un discours
le discours c'était quoi c'est que
valérie pécresse on a salué sa campagne
salué sa nouba tivité
la priorité aujourd'hui c'est de
préserver l'unité du parti en essayant
de trouver cet espace de départ le
alexandra dublanche un espace politique
entre l'extrême droite d'un côté
emmanuel macron de l'autre pour avoir
une droite indépendante et j'ai eu au
téléphone hier après midi sophie primas
qui a participé à but à celui sénatrice
sénatrice des yvelines et on écoute
cette position d'unité
donc aujourd'hui on a obtenu que tout le
monde soit sur cette position là par un
vote mais voilà après on va voir dans le
temps dans l'eau si on arrive à avoir
suffisamment de force pour la tenir ca c
je continue à avoir quand même quelques
inquiétudes l'avenir à court terme c'est
évidemment l'enjeu des législatives et
puis ensuite c'est l'avenir du parti de
notre chance le politique pour pour la
suite et donc de ses deux de ces deux
visions est sorti à la nécessité de
devoir rester uni indépendant et de
devoir continuer à tracer la route d'un
parti qui soit
dans la coalition avec emmanuel macron
ni dans l'opposition à des valeurs
ancestrales de notre parti qui sont des
compromissions avec l'extrême droite
voilà donc rester indépendant ne pas
faire de compromission ni à sa droite ni
à sa gauche et gérard larcher a publié
un communiqué de presse hier soir à 19h
suite aux politiques tardif ensuite aux
réunions aussi à l'assemblée nationale
le groupe parlementaire des républicains
s'est réuni à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat donc ils annoncent ce qui
votera emmanuel macron dans son
communiqué qu'il faut conserver cette
droite indépendante et ce matin
jean-françois copé qui était chez nos
confrères de france info parler d'une
possibilité en tout cas c'est sa volonté
et c'est la position qu'il a défendu
hier au bureau politique c'est de faire
un pacte de gouvernement avec emmanuel
macron donc on voit que l'unité est de
façade
il ya déjà des divisions qu'on peut voir
avec on voit apparaître dès aujourd'hui
il en avait déjà parlé dès dimanche soir
copé en demandant en faisant un appel à
maquereau en disant il faut ouvrir
les sarkozy je crois mais de proposer
leurs actes enfin je sais pas trop ce
que
copé au président sarkozy mais
les télévisions des yvelines j'aurais
citer également le tweet de 20h02 de
pierre bédier président du comité
départemental terminal tu dis je suis
gaulliste et j'appelle à ce qu'on
soutienne et me donne un contrat
symbolique chiraquiens
et un phénomène qui très intéressant on
va voir ce que va donner des listes
hâtives et est-ce qu'on n'est pas dans
une situation vous avez des partis
nationaux
lrm rassemblement national qui gagne des
élections nationales et puis des partis
comme le lr comme le ps qui sont quand
même encore assez bien implantés
localement
et on aurait au foot deux sortes de ces
cétacés la saison je sais pas si c'est
la russe n'a pas réussi à s'implanter
dans les mairies d'andorre les députés
c'est autre chose mais enfin dans les
autres rédactions no c'est clairement
une question et c'est ce que soulever
d'ailleurs jean françois copé que
aujourd'hui jean françois copé veut
faire un pacte de gouvernement avec
emmanuel macron pour que justement les
républicains devienne un une
implantation locale
pour emmanuel macron il veut jouer sur
ce discours le fait que ce serait la
représentation des territoires disons et
avancer avec leurs idées de
décentralisation parce qu'on sait que
valérie pécresse avait des propositions
sur la décentralisation ce que n'a
peut-être pas emmanuel macron en tout
cas ce qui ne met pas en avant dans son
programme vélo prêcher pour ma paroisse
mais j'aurais quand même rappeler que le
diprivan un des partis qui est le plus
d'élus locaux dans les communes de moins
de 50 pieds d'habitants et par
conséquent on peut servir aussi d'une
très très belles jambes locales pour
aider effectivement onéreux même si
besoin est nous sommes quand même un
parti centriste j'aurais pas quel est le
seul à penser qu'il serait présent parce
que je crois que sans lui dit il y
aurait quelques difficultés à gagner à
la fois des régions et des départements
et des communes mais est ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que on n'imagine pas
aler faire 4 % aux législatives
nous verrons ce pas le nombre alors il
ya un gros avantage vous savez quand
même que la vie politique française est
financé par le résultat et le nombre de
votes du premier tour des législatives
donc c'est important parce que comme l
air et face à des difficultés
financières le nombre de votants à
permettre à financer fonction du parti
c'est la première mais patrice il faut
surtout avoir au moins 51 bon sens pour
faire élire ses députés mais est-ce que
sinon on pouvait avoir un fort taux si
vous êtes en dessous du parti
majoritaire ça sera ce qui s'est passé
la dernière fois vous aurez un maximum
d'élèves rem qui seront élus il ya
peut-être une différence très importante
c'est qu'il ya plus de l'effet waouh la
première fois lorsqu'il ya les vieux
cons à élise et didier qu'on connaissait
ni d'eve ni d'adam qui était maintenant
du territoire qui est coté à ans qu'on
connaît toujours pas d'ailleurs par
quelques uns très limité
de là à dire que les habitants des
connaissent le winner députés
c'est à dire que oui c'était les députés
gaullistes du taux de de gaulle qui
accrédite la thèse soulevées par notre
collègue ici présent c'est que
probablement qu'elle est vraie mort a
besoin plus que la dernière fois d'avoir
une emprise de cale de gens quand même
un petit peu connu lyon et ont reconnu
sur des territoires et peut-être que la
porte ouverte par l air ou lui dei par
rapport à cela peut-être une façon
effectivement de faire élire des députés
pour soutenir la majorité attention
après au risque que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure d'avoir une majorité composite
dans lequel vous avez du mal à faire
bloc et d'avoir une voix d'hier unanimis
pas unanimité d une grosse majorité pour
voter certains projets de loi quand vous
avez allait presque des frondeurs au
sein ce que vous auriez recomposé pour
garantir d'avoir nombre de députés élus
mais là vous partez du principe que ce
serait emmanuel macron qui serait élu
vous avez raison
dans ce cas de figure c'est la
cohabitation parce que je ne crois
absolument pas ce que les français
soient la capacité d'envoyer une
majorité d'élus à rennes à l'assemblée
nationale il faudrait que je suis en
majorité lrm olympien avait pas de
partie mais c'était ne
suis pas sûr
cette auto satisfait 80 qui disait on
aura la majorité aux législatives à leur
ticket raz-de-marée
l'effet légitimité à toujours jouer
maintenant est-ce qu'il rejouera cette
fois ci c'est une question qui jusque là
par rapport aux propos de laurent est ce
que lui dit localement pourrait faire
alliance avec l hérault même alors il ya
un bureau politique qui a lieu ce matin
au moment où ce moment même et donc de
seront fixés à midi sur à la fois le
soutien que nous apporterons ou pas mais
enfin j'ose imaginer que le souvenir
nous la portons envers les mâcon je me
sens pas soutenir marine le pen et je
crois qu'à ce moment là je ne
représenterai plus dès la semaine
prochaine je vais très clair sur ce
point je pense qu'ils sont là il faut
donner de la visibilité de l'horizon
probablement à nos engagements et donc
de là à dire qu'il y aura un soutien bah
ça va dépendre de la locale mais si ça
peut se prendre de l'eau ça dépendra
logique avec nous mêmes on est un bloc
d'élus centristes de républicains donner
nos craintes d' humaniste et par
conséquent on prendra une position qui
sera certainement nick pardon après si
certains effectivement veulent prendre
des décisions unilatérales je pense
qu'ils sont appelés à quitter lui dit et
je faisais une petite blagounette on
parle en d'horizon et pourquoi pas
rejoint d'horizon s'ils ne veulent pas
rejoindre à la république en marche
directement
dans le parti de m il faut se projeter
pardon excusez moi je rappelle que moi
c'était quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est quand même un accroc ne peut pas
se représenter pour un troisième mandat
donc du coup et en même temps ce dans
une forme de liberté de décision
puisqu'il est issu g à aucune réflexion
ça serait intéressant à voir mais par
conséquent il faut déjà travailler avec
est ce que l'on fait après et la
question de qu'est ce que l'on fait
après dans la recomposition convient de
parler c'est quid du futur candidat
représentant les idées sans trop droite
gauche de l'allée macron effectivement
probablement edouard philippe en tout
cas c'est comme ça qu'on pense et du
coup comment se recompose droit et l air
et lui dit les autres partis centristes
par rapport à edouard philippe est un
peu plus clair centre droit qui n'est
centre gauche c'est pour ça qu'il faut
se positionner à mon avis maintenant
pour le futur et c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les yvelines peut
être un mini laboratoire de ce que
pourrait être la droite française après
cette élection parce que aujourd'hui
quand on regarde le conseil
départemental pierre bédier il dirige
une majorité
avec la modem avec lui d y avec les
républicains et avec horizon puisque
karl olive le maire de poissy qui
soutient emmanuel macron qui fait partie
de ce mouvement horizons et bien et
vice-président le meurtre pharmacie la
majorité je sais pas s'il a encore son
poste de vice président du conseil
départemental des yvelines ainsi qu'à y
siègent dans la majorité de pierre
bédier aujourd'hui donc ça peut être un
modèle de ce que peut devenir la droite
française la droite de gouvernement
française un mot sur le peut-être
demander ce que le phénomène mélenchon
parce que c'était quand même intéressant
il n'est pas passé loin de là du
deuxième tour
[Musique]
on regarde d'ailleurs les les scores
assez incroyable dans les yvelines
activement jean luc mélenchon bon faut
le dire un c'est dans les quartiers
prioritaires dans les communes urbaines
est plutôt orienté à gauche qui s'est
imposé qu'il arrive en tête des communes
avec en fait c'est un électorat non pas
ouvriers parce que l'électorat ouvrier
avait plus été capté par marie dans
l'arène le département des yvelines mais
plutôt quartiers populaires et cas voilà
sartrouville par exemple trappe trappe
il dépasse les 60% à trappes même chose
pour la commune des mureaux alors en
fait jean luc mélenchon il était déjà en
tête dans ces communes en 2010 7 mai
mais il est là et augmenter et en fait
ce qu'on constate c'est que dans ces
communes ya eu plus de participation et
finalement la participation à participer
à ce que à ce que jean luc mélenchon
obtiennent des scores vraiment beaucoup
plus important encore dans ces villes
60% à trappes c'est quand même
sur ces 60 % à trappes pour mélenchon
ils se répartissent comment derrière
par rapport sur le deuxième tour
alors tout le monde on s'est pas passé
en plus jean luc mélenchon ne donne une
consigne de vote il dit pas de vote pour
à une marine le pen donc après c'est
comme en 2017 jean luc mélenchon on le
sait en 2017 il y avait eu des votes
blancs il y avait eu une explosion des
votes blancs il y avait eu des voix qui
ont dû aller pour emmanuel macron on
verra pour ce second tour après et des
voix qui est bon
d comprennent trois c'est-à-dire un
tiers voterai marine le pen un tiers
macro et un tiers blanc ou ne viendrait
pas et c'est l'avant vincent couronne
avait raison tout à l'heure de souligner
que finalement marine le pen avait un
une fait campagne sur le pouvoir d'achat
et jean luc mélenchon aussi c'est
peut-être là dessus qu'ils peuvent se
rejoindre c'est parce qu'on pense
vincent couronne
je pense que le score de mélenchon il
est quand même en grande partie due à un
vote utile et donc il faut faire
attention à ce que ce score qui était
effectivement assez paris qui est une
victoire avec un échec françois en
victoire était pour la france insoumise
que ce score en fait ne soit pas juste
une bulle temporaire et donc ça on verra
en fait après deuxième tour on verra
pour les législatives aussi si le parti
communiste le parti socialiste ont
vraiment été dévitalisées par la france
soumise aussi au contraire il n'avait
qu'un effet vote utile est ce que je
note en tout cas par rapport aux à la
question du pouvoir d'achat
la question aussi de la justice sociale
quatre questions traitées par jean luc
mélenchon sait que jusque-là mélenchon
insister beaucoup lors de ses campagnes
sur la 6ème république or les questions
institutionnelles et constitutionnelles
en général passionne pas les foules ici
il a très peu parlé de 6ème république
même si ça fait toujours de son parti de
son programme pour plus parler des
questions et bien évidemment social
économique et puis évidemment forcément
alors une semaine plus international et
diplomatique donc c'est ça aussi qu'il
ya sans doute aidé à le porter un peu
plus aux affaires que son programme soit
plus incarné par des mesures qui étaient
plus facilement identifiable par les par
les électeurs plutôt que de parler d'une
vième république qui n'est qu'une
coquille dans laquelle il faut pouvoir
mettre des politiques et là il a parlé
de ses politiques il est assez clair que
si vous êtes un électeur de gauche et vu
la nullité des autres candidats
il y avait comme une tentation de dire
voilà je peux aller voter pour quelqu'un
qui va faire 1,7 pour cent je vais
peut-être voter pour quelqu'un qui peut
être deuxième tour il ya probablement
une partie importante de vote utile dans
le dans le trade monstre heures de
mélenchon non j'ai l'impression que si
vous êtes un acteur de gauche et parti
socialiste issu du siècle des lumières
qui aiderait combattu pour la laïcité
etc moi j'aurais du mal à voter les jean
luc mélenchon compte tenu de la
typologie des électeurs j'ai vu venir de
mon bureau de vote donc je pense qu'il
est de gauche probablement mais très
très à gauche quand même parce que si
vous êtes de gauche au centre gauche je
me sens pas enfin je ne sais pas - les
amis socialistes n'ont pas votre pas
mélenchon je suis d'accord avec vous
mais il y avait aussi mais il y avait
aussi un côté on va tomber le sont ces
gens là sont dit on va où va empêcher
marine le pen
donc voilà c'est pas du tout aveu je
pense qu'il ya pas un vote d'adhésion
pour mélenchon dont beaucoup de gens qui
ont voté mélenchon c'était simplement un
vote un peu par par défaut d'un rock est
vu comme le dit très justement pas
triste on va pas voter pour quelqu'un
d'aussi pitoyable que anne hidalgo on va
pas voter pour ajouter aux personnes
voilà nous accordons que après il faut
regarder aussi sur le terrain puisque on
parle des livres le programme s'est par
ailleurs de mental de 2,2 de mélenchon
était plutôt que si bien que ceux déjà
dauphin de lille a également dit qu'une
grosse partie des quelques élus locaux
qui soutenait mélenchon de les yvelines
on va prendre le maire de trappes par
exemple ce qu'il était donné mirabel il
ya une typologie tout à fait
particulière également à on va dire
surfer sur aussi une tranche de
population particulière dans ces
communes qui ont été appelés à voter
mélenchon par différents biais qui sont
aperçus et moi qui sont parfois un peu
prompts religieux on va se le dire parce
que la désinformation qui nous le pauvre
il ya ce surf elle a évidemment et du
coup je les vois moins voter au deuxième
tour parce que pour le coup je pense
qu'ils sont ni macro ni stn omni voilà
il ya mon avis en plus sur un petit peu
manipulée dans tout ça je suis pas
forcément sûr qu'à la finale jean luc
mélenchon les aiderait plus que ça et je
pense que cela ils vont plutôt vers
l'abstention parce qu'ils ne reviendront
pas au bureau de vote et moi qui ai
prise d'un bureau de vote j'ai vu
beaucoup de gens puisque vous suit
puisqu'on alain fisch qui vais voter
pour la première fois mais y compris
qu'ils n'avaient pas été pas la première
fois qu'ils avaient pas 18 ans alors
qu'ils avaient 35 ans et un g1 de t pain
pas vraiment surpris les voir voter
voilà et donc on a une progression sur
mon bureau de vote dans un quartier
plutôt populaire puisque la clé de 5
hier l encours est plutôt un quartier
populaire et dans lequel ces gens sont
venus voter vous voyez bien parce qu'on
leur avait dit qu'il fallait voter et
donc ces gens là je les vois pas prêt à
les trier
perdra donc je pense mon alimentation
effectivement les yvelines de
l'extension et avec une disparition
quand même assez importante des des gens
qui votent pour mélenchon justement
issus des quartiers sera intéressant de
voir le deuxième tournant dès 15h et là
où il était en tête nicolas je voulais
juste revenir sur le vote utile
finalement le vote utile tête résume
bien ce scrutin parce que ya eu un vote
utile à gauche il fallait absolument
voter pour le candidat de gauche qu'ils
allaient lâcher aux arrivées au second
tour mais il ya eu le même phénomène
aussi à droite finalement certains
électeurs de valérie pécresse et
notamment je pense dans les îles livre
qui m'a convoqué emmanuel macron parce
qu'il savait très peur et de l'horreur
d'ailleurs qui est un mélange où le pen
au 2è exactement et parce qu'il
incarnait une certaine idée de la droite
qui est proche de valérie pécresse tout
mène et peut-être dans certaines des
lecteurs zemmour ou voter le pen en
voyant qu'elle avait des chevaux ça l'a
finalement c'est peut-être l'extrême
droite où il n'y a pas eu de vote utile
parce que c'est assez partagés peut-être
dans les derniers jours parce que
effectivement zemmour descendez dans les
sondages et puis il ya des électeurs qui
se sont dit finalement marine le pen
effectivement avoir la chance d'accéder
au second tour et du coup on va voter
près mais finalement l'extrême droite
c'est là où il ya eu le moins de vote
utile et ça a moins impacté les scores
des deux candidats on peut voir derrière
et les votes de le pen et de et de
zemmour dans les yvelines c'est assez
intéressant ou est-ce qu'il faut des
démons score alors marine le pen et ben
on peut dire qu'on tient une sorte de
croissants du rassemblement national qui
part du sud yvelines qui longe toute la
frontière avec le rpt et loire qui
remonte jusqu'à l'heure et en fait ça
fait en sorte de croissants sur toute la
partie ouest du département jusqu'au
nord du département dans des petites
communes qui soit entre 200 et 1000
habitants j'ai un chiffre c'est donc
marine le pen arrive en tête dans
quarante et une communes des yvelines là
quand même voilà mais c'est des petites
communes avec
et rural mais ruralité mais vraiment
très éloignées des grandes villes parce
que finalement dans certaines dans
certaines zones rurales et je pense par
exemple à la plaine de versailles
villages autour de lait des villages
autour de maule les villages autour de
feucherolles saint nom la bretèche
classe à votre mac rond donc c'est de la
ruralité mais c'est pour emmanuel macron
parce qu'on est proche heures et des
heures
je veux dire non mais vous avez divine
mais quand on descend aussi leur embolie
teint et vers la vallée de chevreuse on
a le même phénomène mais finalement il
ya rural où il ya très peu d'habitants
mais ça vote emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron arrive en tête dans ces communes
200 une commune ou dans lesquels
emmanuel macron à est en tête il faisait
beau à la est alors eric zemmour
2-2 score notoire c'est versailles où il
arrive en second tiers d'ici et le
chesnais rocancourt il arrive aussi en
seconde position
donc bon malgré l'enjeu c'est de
versailles étant à peu près
sociologiquement
macron emmanuel macron arrive largement
en tête à la versa mais eric zemmour
arrive à récolter 10 9% des suffrages
loin devant valérie pécresse va hériter
quatrième pause lise position juste
derrière jean luc mélenchon c'est quand
même là aussi c'est assez assez
novateur il est attendu
position le pen alors d'après d'autres
assurent les syndicalistes dans les
yvelines veut dire qu'il n'est pas forte
traditionnellement elle n'est pas forte
les ailes et les trois au quatrième jeu
pendant les événements troisième source
dans les yvelines elle est juste
derrière jean luc mélenchon mais acea
seul mois quand même et finalement quand
on regarde
marine
un électorat ouvrier finalement parce
qu'on regarde il ya vraiment deux scores
assez flagrant et qui illustre bien ce
propos là c'est que marine le pen est en
tête à gargenville et à flins-sur-seine
flins sur seine où est située l'usiné
historique de renault et dans ces deux
communes là il marine le pen arrive
largement en tête il faut savoir que
gargenville c'est quand même sept mille
habitants et flins-sur-seine ses 3000
habitants c'est les deux bleus plus
grosse commune où elle elle arrive en
tête dans le département après le reste
comme je veux pas fait d'une 77 %
c'est-à-dire très très loin quand même
de deux son score national et quand on
regarde certaines communes aussi on voit
qu'il ya un vote contestataire quand
même parce que c'est des zones où on a
pu en est on l'a suivi d'ailleurs
pendant la crise des filets jaunes
leschi les jeunes se mobiliser dans ces
zones là c'est
toi quand on s'approche de la frontière
avec le département de l'eure je pense
notamment à ces communes de
bonnières-sur-seine de freneuse ou de
mantes-la-ville montre la vie de jean
luc mélenchon est en tête juste derrière
c'est marine le pen et dans plusieurs
communes il ya ce phénomène là où la
ville qui a été l'été dirigé par le
ballon fraude à cela le passé 2014 et
2020 mais on voit que dans ces communes
là et ben c'est un vote contestataire
puisque c'est marine le pen qui en tête
jean luc mélenchon derrière ou vice
versa jean luc mélenchon en tête et
marine le pen juste derrière dans les
yvelines elle vous fait pas très très
fort rebond + parti socialiste
et jean lassalle
un peu plus
tôt son département favori mais
vêtements intéressant de voir la
répartition des élections locales qui
vont avoir du mal ces demeures rapport à
ce que vous venez d'annoncer
effectivement c'est
mélenchon fait 54% en tête il arrive en
tête avec 54% des voix mais c'est enfin
pas avec la même intensité il n'avait
pas le même niveau de ceux de suffrages
mais jean-luc mélenchon était déjà en
tête au premier tour en 2010 est à
mantes-la-jolie aller au terme in part
en se projetant un peu sur le 24 parce
que je pense que florence est très
inquiète et que va-t-il se passer le
mode 4 avril donc
[Musique]
alors on voit déjà débat d'abord il ya
une vraie campagne et se dire que ça y
est macro est entré en campagne ce qui
n'avait pas fait
un premier renoncement qui a extrêmement
inquiétant c'est à dire que un des
marqueurs de sa campagne c'était cette
retraite à 65 ans il allait l'imposé
quoi qu'il se passe etc et puis delà des
lendemains et oui j'envisage un
référendum et puis 65 oui ça serait
peut-être 64 et puis on verra un peu
trop s'inquiéter ou ajuste son club pour
inventer quelque chose c'est de dire il
est cohérent et emmanuel macron et
cohérent parce que finalement c'est ça
ce qui a défini emmanuel macron sait
faire des compromis absolument pas ce
que c'est il aidé ni de droite ni de
gauche et donc il va essayer de fallois
rassembler un maximum de personnes lange
et il fait ce constat il fait ce constat
qui comme elle qui est quand même vrai
le front républicain n'existe plus on
voit bien à l'air ne dit pas voilà on ne
donne pas de consigne de vote donc ce
qui était le jeudi en 2002 des huit dès
20h05 des socialistes appelés à voter
chirac est bordée de deux étudiants et
lens 2010 est ce ça n'existe plus donc à
partir de là c'est le vrai qui dit il
faut inventer quelque chose ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire essayer de rassembler
belle et d'aller prendre un peu passé
mais dans son délire
s'il
fallait rassembler puisque c'est en même
temps
il était déjà
sur leurs frais parce que on se dit tous
les jours il va renoncer sur quelque
chose quoi pour essayer de ratisser le
le plus largement possible donc ça c'est
que soient les questions de rester droit
dans ses bottes comme disait sur
quelques trucs là je pense que c'est
bien de temps en tendres restée droite
dans ses bottes parce que sinon je la
leur pour expliquer aussi l'oiseau
ce qui est là où je rejoins quand même
jean-charles pour une fois c'est que
samedi il est faut rester 65 65 ans et
lundi ou mardi li fu faut revoir parce
que finalement il ya une opposition
que ça n'emporte pas l'adhésion est donc
et donc 64 mais oui non mais pourquoi
toi sa me disent nous savons pourquoi
pas une minute
oui mais
il fait mieux que ce à quoi ce qui s'est
passé les habitants souvent mais on ne
savait pas qu'ils sont plus coûteux que
tout père et en plus il a lancé un
référendum sur l urgence du riz
comment voulez-vous du candidat qu'ils
paniquent comment voulez-vous tout
perdre quand on quand vous êtes quand
même face à l'al combien de générations
de la nationale à un moment il ya aussi
quand même un réflexe qui fait que des
votes vont aller vers lui même si six
décennies c'est ce que vous faites vous
merci pour pour conclure
je vais conclure de manière très
décevante patrie suis désolé mais en
fait sur cette question là moi je trouve
que ils ont peint dans cet entre deux
tours marine le pen et emmanuel macron
ont du talent une tâche impossible à
réaliser ils doivent tous les deux à la
fois à séduire l'électoral les
républicains et l'électorat de gauche
notamment de jean luc mélenchon je ne
sais pas comment tous les deux vont
réussir à faire ce grand écart aller
chercher les voix de mélenchon c'est le
risque de lâcher la proie pour l'ombre
et en même temps ne pas aller le faire
baisser le risque de se priver de tout
un vivier électoral pour pouvoir
franchir la barre la barre du deuxième
tour honnêtement je ne sais pas comment
ils vont faire
laurent je pense que comme ils vont
faire il faut qu'il reste alors là pour
le coup j'ai des droits dans leurs
bottes et dans ce qu'ils sont et à mon
sens il faut miser sur une abstention
des électeurs de mélenchon faut faire en
sorte qu'ils n'aillent pas voter en fait
vincent c'est horriblement
antidémocratique ce que je dis mais
quand on peut pas les réunir il faut
surtout pas qu'ils aient voté oui ça y
est la dimension de plus
oui mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
c'est à la république en marche
effectivement avant le premier tour qui
disait c'est terrible de se dire qu'en
réalité plus l'abstention sera forte en
fait plus emmanuel macron de chances de
se faire des voix au premier tour
voilà c'est vrai que le problème se pose
aussi pour le deuxième tour donc on peut
pas inciter les gens à rester chez eux
et à ne pas voter évidemment pas il faut
que les gens aillent voter mais c'est un
vrai problème effectivement
il ya les vacances en plus mais c'est
quand même ça va être passionnant parce
que c'est vrai que on voit que ça peut
être s'est pas forcé mais ça pourrait
être scrutin serré et c'est quand même
étonnant comme évolution c'est qu'il ya
20 ans aurait pensé qu'un le pen
pourrait devenir président de la
république
c'est pas grave ça va pierre chaque
élection c est à la dernier au célibat
oui la prochaine ça peut être
vraiment minima barnier on est juste
pour conclure de l'église de 2017
emmanuel macron a récolté 77 15 % des
voix au second tour contre 22 85% pour
marine le pen c'est à dire plus que
niveau social 68
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à tous les
tous les cinq on se retrouvera sans
doute le 25 ou le 26 avril vont
augmenter et peut-être la semaine
prochaine déjà pour voir un peu ce qui
va se passer merci
[Musique]